welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's moon knight's most
chilling contribution to the mcu yet has
been ethan hawk's villain arthur hero
and the mythological being he channels
emmett the egyptian devourer of the dead
who judges people's past presence and
futures upon cosmic scales and upon
failing that morality test your soul
gets tell them stephen
and our friends at short box start
giving away the first solo moon night
comic from 1976. stick around to the end
of the video to learn how to enter to
win that on the spectrum of marvel
villains harrow and ahmed fall somewhere
between thanos who chaotically sentences
half of everyone to death with a coin
flip and kang aka he who remains and
loki who through the tva judges outline
violators according to some unseen
transcript of their destinies but it's
the connection between amit and kang
that we really should take a closer look
at because the specific way they judge
and sentence their defendants for future
crimes is not only the same philosophy
essentially but hard evidence in both
moon knight and loki point to a very
possible shared history between these
two figures history that could explain
why everyone in the mcu currently faces
some kind of cosmic legal trouble i mean
thank god we now got lawyers like
she-hulk and matt murdock on retainer
now a reminder that the best way to
support new rockstars is to get our
limited edition moon night inspired
shirt tomb of the moon guide which will
unlock the option to write in a custom
shout out for our after show new
rockstarsmerch.com okay in moonlight
episode one arthur hero drains an old
woman's life force after a negative
judgment i've been good my entire life i
believe you but the scales see
everything perhaps it's something that
lies ahead he later explains amit's
judgment she grew eerie of having to
wait for sinners to commit their crime
before punishing them would you wait to
weed a garden till after the roses were
dead the justice of amit surveys the
whole of our lives past present future
she knows what we've done and what we
will do philosophically this mirrors the
function of the tba and loki which
prunes innocent people from merely
unknowingly living their lives contrary
to what he who remains had scripted for
them in his sacred timeline the tva
pruned sylvie when she was a young girl
in asgard presumably merely for existing
turning her into a self-fulfilling
prophecy of a temporal terrorist what
was my nexus event why did you bring me
in what does it matter it was enough to
take my life from me and lead to all of
this must have been important so what
was it i don't remember all of this
pruning was directed by he who remains
who like amit passes these judgments
with a divine insight into everyone's
future i already know what's going to
happen i know it all and i've seen it
all however he who remains was not
ordained by any higher power to do this
he took initiative he weaponized eliath
ended the multiverse of war between the
kang variants and established the tva's
judicial hierarchy to execute his vision
the same goes for amit when you think
about it in egyptian mythology ahmet is
not the ultimate judge that
responsibility lies with anubis who
holds the scales and weighs your heart
against the weight of a feather and if
you fail that then you are fed to ahmet
but in hero's tattoo ahmet has taken the
scales clutching them in her mouth and
much more aggressive posture so on one
hand we got one destiny judge who
violently took the responsibility of
assessing the fates of all of mankind
using a weaponized goliath and 31st
century magic and then on the other hand
another destiny judge who wants to
snatch this responsibility from a god
above her paygrade using a weaponized
avatar in her ancient magic now this
connection gets especially interesting
when you consider the various nods to
ancient egypt we saw collected as he who
remains trophies in his void these
include the pyramids of giza and the
sphinx pyramids that will appear in this
moon night series in loki those egyptian
landmarks were nods to the way kang kept
in his kingdom of chronopolis in the
comics relics from his time in ancient
egypt when he used the pseudonym of
pharaoh rama tut he actually used the
sphinx as a vehicle to travel through
time it's actually how nathaniel
richards got to ancient egypt in the
first place he remains in loki
referenced this past life i've been
dubbed many names by many people a ruler
a conqueror a jerk that ruler identity
he was referring to was very likely his
time as pharaoh rama tut in ancient
egypt and in moon knight episode 1
arthur harrow did drop this interesting
line about amit's backstory but she was
betrayed by indolent fellow gods by even
her own avatar betrayed by her own
avatar for any human avatar to be able
to betray an egyptian deity to bypass
the divine higher power and collude with
the other gods without amit noticing
that human must have been someone of
remarkable intelligence boldness and
power among an otherwise superstitious
and god fury in ancient egypt's society
so i think the likeliest suspect for
that traitorous avatar if it is ever
revealed in this series or a future
title and if it is a familiar name that
we have heard in the mcu before is
pharaoh ramatutt aka kang the conqueror
nathaniel richards could have used his
temporal tech to transport himself back
to ancient egypt to lord over this
society maybe the guy who even helped
the ancient egyptians become such a
dominant civilization by the way i found
it interesting that the eternals film
showed the ways they helped ancient
sumerians babylonians ancient india the
aztecs even nods to ancient greece and
the ancient norse with shout outs to
thor and odin but completely skipped
over ancient egypt almost as if marvel
could have some other origin story in
mind to explain how comic book lore
intersected with that real world history
so kang's experience with amit might
have been what inspired him to retire
from his life of boredom ruling over
human societies throughout history and
instead lured over all of time from his
citadel using a judicial system in the
same philosophical framework as amit's
judgment and by betraying amit and
helping the other members of the iniad
lock her away he would guarantee that
only he now has the power to judge
people based on their destinies and that
no other divine interference could ever
complicate his unilateral vision and now
as we look ahead notice how both he
remains and ahmet fear the same kind of
threat ahmet was unable to judge steven
grant the scales never settling this
chaos in you similarly what did he
remains pose as the alternative to his
stifling order um
that's the gambit stifling order or
cataclysmic chaos duos like loki and
sylvie steven grant and mark spector
these are both chaotic dyads wrestling
over control over each other the same
could be said for wanda maximoff and in
multiverse madness footage we are seeing
two projections of wanda all three of
these duos could be chaos magic
incarnate maybe even what the mcu will
call nexus beings threats that do not
fit into the mold designed by
authorities like kang like amit and
whatever multiversal judicial body
doctor strange is now facing an
authority that wanda will try to destroy
order versus chaos and this kang variant
could have even been the author of the
constitution that all these higher
powers of the mcu abide by and enforce
over their jurisdictions that's strange
and loki and cersei are now running
afoul of i guess it'll all just depend
folks on who exactly will be sitting in
those other thrones in multiverse of
madness and again we are partnering with
short box to give away a rated copy of
marvel spotlight 28 from 1976 the first
solo comic for the hero moon knight it's
currently valued at over 250 dollars and
you gotta imagine that that number is
going to be going up up and up with all
the interest in the oscar isaac led
series short box is the easiest and
safest way to buy and sell graded comic
books you can download short boxed for
free on ios and android they have an
incredible selection of graded comics
everything from the recent favorites to
the most valuable comics in the world
they're currently spotlighting a bunch
of issues featuring moon knight
including werewolf by night issue 32 the
first ever appearance of moon night all
orders are fully protected and insured
for buyers and sellers thousands of the
most respected dealers and collectors in
the industry trust shortbox and use it
every day to enter the giveaway visit
shortbox.com new rockstars to enter and
to receive a promo code for 15 off your
first short boxed order again that's
shortbox.com new rockstars you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you